okay well four people joining us on the
live stream this is another episode in
internal design meeting for incremental
language development efforts for the
next version wolfin language is kind of
the last stop for a bunch of interesting
utility language functions before they
are released in the next version so we
are looking at some documentation and we
are starting with sequence split have I
seen this page before or not perhaps
they don't remember we have discussed
also sequence replaced recently and
perhaps we looked at them together they
are very close to each other okay so
let's see so as you saw the motivation
for these functions is coming from the
string family so this follows string
split right so okay fair enough
I mean this is what as a discussed okay
what does the so I don't think there's a
lot that's controversial here are these
things knitted or not I don't think so
do you remember sugar notes okay do we
consider this experimental or we yeah
this looks pretty solid to me I think so
like I said oh just replace okay alright
okay so let's see so let's go ahead and
knit the sky there there are no weird
cases that we have to worry about here
no between sequences defined by Patrick
does not conclude the sequences
themselves right so that's the same okay
so that's pointing to string split here
why are we pointing the I guess that's
right I guess that's right have we have
we pointed back to sequence split from
these
no I've just updated the backlinks of
the sequence family but not for the
other symbols okay okay well let's see
so this should probably yeah so it
should go right there before sequence
before string split right yes exactly
like I'm not even sure that secret that
string split should be I mean I I think
I think it's fine there because it's
it's one of those split family all right
okay fair enough okay split by my by the
way did you put keywords and sequence
split I I guess yes so split by where do
we want to mention it there we gather by
is clearly more relevant this is a
partition is probably less relevant so
let's put it in there okay and string
split did you point back to sequence
split no I don't even sure that split
itself should be mentioned here well
maybe it could be after sequence split
okay now what about what is chaos you
can see it doesn't need to be mentioned
here yeah the other connections are more
for the sequence part of it I mean if
we're interesting sequence split while
I'm imagining all the other sequence
functions on pattern sequence yes
perhaps actually sequence replace and
suppose cases are more important and
since Plitt here I would think so okay
sub sequences we need to back point from
that and sequence alignment likewise
okay so let's go to sequence replace and
let's see where it is on guide pages how
come on you cost you place why wasn't it
a big in the edges is it new humph why
does this go now let's look at the
Latian see whether we have the sequence
family I say finding sub lists finding
sub lists okay rearranging restructuring
lists
perhaps we could change finding sub
lists to list manipulation and we put I
agree but but this has other this is all
extraction things I see so what are the
two that we were missing it's just
sequence replace and sequence split yes
well I mean that seems to me it's in
this family here right yeah we could add
another line there with it - yes
but these are some pretty major
functions like join and partition it's
on
well I don't know whether these make the
cut or whether we should just add I kind
of think what we should do is add I
still think that perhaps you have even a
new section with a new delimiter
dedicated to sub lists now that we have
like five all right all right fine all
right so all right so let's have a
section here called finding and
manipulating sub lists and then what we
can do is move those guys down there and
maybe we can have a separate line here
for sequence split and sequence replace
I guess okay but now on this page on the
rearranging and restructuring lists page
we probably want to have so there we've
got sub sequences okay so let's let's
have a section here called maybe
sequence or interior operations we have
that seems sensible yes I agree
okay and we might want to actually point
this thing here over to that
rearranging and restructuring lists
thing as well so okay you know that
would potentially allow us to not list
all of these here where do we even list
count here we don't even list count here
because it's list manipulation so we
don't really list that so I'm going to
let's let's look back at this okay
sequence position
I suspect sequence cases is more
important than sequence position mmm
angry and let's do sequence split here
or do a sequence replace is probably
more important and then just do that
yeah and then let's point to this page
and now here we can say so no this is
because this is a page about it doesn't
would not include count and things like
that right yeah so so I'm afraid we're
gonna have to put sequence count on this
page here for math and counting
operations right sat in which for which
it's quite relevant actually okay so
that means we have to go down there okay
now wait a minute sequence position
doesn't really belong unfortunately a
sequence position does not belong and
finding well finding the manipulating
sub lists it belongs but it does not
belong and rearranging in restructuring
lists a I guess we can organize them by
putting all the sequence together or by
action as you are doing now right well
that's okay hold on we can okay so here
we've got a look at this we've already
got sequence oriented operations right
here and that already goes to this whole
business
okay yeah that's a good page to put them
but do we want um I guess we want do we
want sequence split and sequence replace
here they don't really belong well the
splitting splitting is a bit of
comparison
I think it's an obscure connection there
I mean okay hold on hold on so we've
already got sequence oriented things
here so that's in counting operations
that's all good okay so here I think
sequence position does not belong here
and maybe what we do yeah let's do this
elements of lists yeah there we go
sequence position all good so the only
thing we might want to do is to put
sequence position in here if we think
it's that important I mean as long as it
is in some page okay so then this one
here what I think we should do then
where do we put sequence so sequence
split can go here we don't need this
separate finding of manipulating sub
lists I don't think we've already got
that in a bunch of places so we could
put a sequence split in here if we want
to or not bother makes sense yes yes you
suggest we put it in this list I'm not
sure really boy I think those are the
most sophisticated functions let's put
it down here okay so we've got this okay
so now we have sequence oriented
operations right so now here we have
sequence split
and that's where we've got replaced part
but now here we can say sequence replace
here and what other ones belong in
sequence oriented operations on this
page nothing I think do we have cases
here we don't need it no we don't have
cases there ok ok then that's fine
split a list at what do we how do we say
it in the actual function itself um at
the position of sequences right split
into sub lists separated by it split a
list um
at subsequence is much in a butter the
sequence is much in the butter
yeah split lost at sequences okay
replace sequences in a list someone on
our chat stream is pointing out how
horrifying it is that the words that
these functions that have the word
sequence in them yeah don't come don't
come actually deal with our sequence
sequence thing you know I have been
trying to stamp out sequence sequence
for what is it 37 years 38 years it was
a construction SNP called NP for null
projection a really stupid name in SMP
and it was horrifying there and it's
horrifying the semantics of it a
horrifying in Wolfram language as well
and I would just be happy if we didn't
have the function sequence and we've
been trying to get rid of that but
what's happened to the flattened
construct have we looked more at the
flattened construct we have been
exploring some details like like whether
it should be hold or I think it's a nice
construct yes it might it might help it
is that the syntax is not clear yet
whether it should take a second argument
with our head in which edicts splices
and this sort of thing I see in the head
enter which it splices exactly
yes that's interesting I mean clearly by
default it should splice until well okay
I would have thought like nothing it
should be a list oriented thing exactly
that should be a different I agree but
it sometimes you need that operation in
other heads and then it would be nice to
be able to control that yes I agree I
mean I think it should take us a second
argument the head into which or the
pattern of heads into which Auto
splicing should occur then he was
suggesting that because the first
argument is going to be a list somehow
the first argument could also indicate
which head is looking for oh you mean oh
I see I see I see I see I see so if the
first argument is if the first argument
of flattened is an F construct then what
do you do yeah you might as well be
going into the F construct because
that's yeah I mean which is nice the
problem here is what happens if F is
trying to evaluate this would force us
to have flattened being hold first oh
but it's horrifying to do that we do not
want to do that yeah we really don't
want to do that that will spoil the
whole point of it I mean we're mostly
dealing with a list if that thing wants
to evaluate then it shouldn't be
splicing well how is it gonna splice if
it evaluates right but I mean perhaps
somebody's constructing a function in
some weird way by tons luck and they can
do it themselves I mean I don't think I
don't think we can provide for that the
value of having it evaluate is much
greater than then some totally weird
case which I can't even imagine yet um
all right let's let's um let's just deal
with the back pointers for sequence
replace
[Music]
merrimette the sequence replaced not
point at sequence split or does it not
need two notes yet updates the the
refuge I think it's obvious okay well
maybe the sick I'm not sure see cases
sequence replace so what's the
difference between yeah I probably needs
to it there oops
okay all right okay so now let's just go
through some of these sequence cases did
we already point this to sequence so
sequence replace yes sequence plead not
yet so we want sequence cases to point
the sequence I think they should all
refer to each other so I could add those
suppose if it were a missing for the
moment okay and which other one do we
want sequence position your sequence
position definitely does want to point
to sequence if they're similar yeah all
right problem is that these functions
have a habit you know we have to not
just because it's new it doesn't mean
it's better I mean you know in other
words we have a tremendous habit I think
I suspect if we did an analysis of this
that there is a a preference for putting
in functions for giving pointers to
functions which are new rather than all
the ones okay so now sequence alignment
um does that want to point to any of
these and does it right now no no I
think C points to sequence position
which is right let me just think for a
second because it's sequence alignment
is looking for common it is breaking the
thing you know what it should point to
to split one thing yes it should point
to the split because that's what it's
doing basically
and I think sequence split should point
to sequence alignment perhaps it does
already it does okay all good all right
I think that's everything for these okay
all right what's next nearest to yes
it's a small thing that Tony detected
but we can look at it after reviewing
the page well it doesn't reflect the
design it's it's not really the fault of
nearest to is it's the fault of nearest
so it's something that we cannot change
but it it affects a bit what Tony does
so the yeah so he was comparing nearest
with take largest yes and the point is a
technologist returns the full key value
pair well nearest only returns the keys
and he was saying that for him it will
be nicer if nearest it returned the full
key value pair so why don't we just give
it a property as you suggest in here we
we could do that I mean it's not going
to be automatic the fact that nearest
you can change now near it or not
absolutely not the nearest is returning
the nearest things not um let's see so
so walk me through this again so the
issue is take largest honor on an
association returns
this is not an association okay I'm
totally confused forget for the moment
about the second part
the first part the first bullet point is
the important thing the fact that take
largest returns an association with key
value pairs well nearest returns just
the keys which I think separately they
are both fine you know that Tony wanted
to use take largest and nearly 16 excite
yet and nearest to in exactly the same
way the operator forms and well yeah I
know he wants to do that because what he
wants to do is he wants to be able to
say entity of City comma a city property
goes to yeah yeah alright five or
nearest to three and for him it's a bit
of a problem that one returns an
association the other one returns a key
but he has solved that he can he can
work around that
boy wait wait a minute what he's
actually got to do for nearest to what
is the actual use case because nearest
to like the city nearest to Los Angeles
or something mmm well there's an example
in the nearest to page it's something
like element whose density is nearest to
four point five grams per cubic
centimeter okay
and I think it's in applications or
scope yeah this one so so there we have
nearest to that value now what's the
problem so internally when he does the
computation if he used take largest five
density take largest five he would get
an association of key value pairs while
with years to he gets just the elements
well so in particular if he says here if
we say the three elements nearest to how
do we do that if I say this thing here
comma three no we don't have that
Oh to wean my gosh well I have no idea
what that just did this is probably not
updated yet he changed this recently
okay fine
but so nearest to I would have thought
nearest to let's take a look there's two
here yeah so the semantics is fine is
typographic error that calm resident of
the right type though you see that okay
okay so go ahead yes so from the point
of view of implicit entity the semantics
is is fine
because you can express what you want is
from the point of view of using it
directly he he has to prepare for some
functions to return some operator forms
to return an association and some other
operator phones to return a list of keys
only so he has to go then and look for
the values and things in that see he has
done that already
mmm no no I just wanted we just wanted
to mention this difference between
arrest and take largest which behave in
a slightly different way well right I
mean because okay I mean the point is
take largest is a take like function
that takes pieces of a thing like a list
or an association and nearest returns
what is nearest and I think what you're
what you're proposing here is that in
this case it should return an
association here whereas nearest as
various things that can return like an
element and index a distance why not
have another one that it says
Association that returns the association
of key value pairs yes yes exactly but
the Association is then what what is the
Association in that case the Association
is I'm really confused I'm sorry what's
the left-hand side of the Association
then
well that's the second part I discussed
there the fact that depending on whether
we feed to nearest an association or a
list of rules they it does exactly it's
basically the same thing but reversed
yes well that's the same as happens and
lots of other functions like all machine
learning functions yeah okay here we
have to to to decide how to return this
new property but you're saying both the
element and the index will returning
both elements and index is that correct
yes but we have to set in which order
and whether it's an association or a
list the rules exactly well so if we
call it association it's pretty obvious
what it's doing
yes that's why I was saying key value
which is kind of more Association like
well cool yes I agree but but what it's
actually returning oh I see it's going
to be a look normally it is returning a
list of results is it not all other
things here return a list of results in
it so if we had a property that said
Association it would return a different
thing which is index arrow element yes
but these properties are referring to
the elements of the list not to the
whole object so in a sense rule or key
value is more yeah but but saying that
it's an association is the outer wrapper
exactly is we also have to say that
yesterday I mean this would make more
sense to say elements plural here given
what we're now saying about Association
yes well these element is referring to
each individual element so these are
properties of each individual object and
that's why we compute the nest
okay let's not this is too complicated
let's not worry about it right now
if Tony has managed to solve this
problem some other way let's I mean I
I'm not sure this is worthwhile do you
think this is worthwhile we don't need
it right now okay
okay fine so let's keep going with
nearest to
did we write this before together or is
this a new thing
I don't remember I may have followed
what we using or their operator forms
like equal to long and by the way that
should be definitely pointed to for here
let's take a look yeah okay all right
fine um surely this should be I don't
know why we're talking about predict and
classify those seem totally irrelevant
here why are we talking about those I
need I mean does it does nearest talk
about those and probably but that's for
very different reasons I mean that would
be this would be more like a classifier
function I see mm-hm
we need to refer to them i we do need to
refer to nearest function here and we
definitely need to refer to equal to
they're probably entity itself or entity
class yeah we can are we referring to
that here actually I would argue that
equal to is really a much now let's see
but brag nearest is clearly the first
one equal to and some other better forms
could be a second before we get to do
nearest yes if we want to put the
emphasis on the operator form then
certainly okay are there any other
operator forms that we want to a an
earthed is equal to not refer to oh yeah
greater equal then right okay okay fine
all right so then we need back pointers
here what just happened why did that not
work
um okay we need back pointers on equal
to probably here two nearest to and
arguably that should also be in greater
equal than what do you think
I think that's useful unless equal than
okay all right okay seems fine to me
future eyes okay is it knitted in guys
[ __ ] no it's not do we have time to
do this netting are we gonna run out of
time if we let's do this let's see let's
put it in one of them at least okay so
this thing goes it goes right there
interesting expressions operator forms
that's person although arguably if we're
going to have inequality inequality we
should include nearest somewhere here
what do you mean inequality well here
look between no I see those are tests
yeah all right fair enough
yeah we could have nearest in that first
line but but the burden no these are
boolean tests
oh I see s with him yeah but that does
fit with these ok so now where is
nearest where does nearest show up let's
look at nearest um as a very bizarre my
gosh the 69 results for nearest what
kinds of places should this show up I
don't know whether this is I mean I
don't know how important this is for
other things other than the implicit
entity stuff where is the implicit
entity stuff discussed looking
knowledgebase you know what we missed a
bunch of things here this is because
here where we talk about entities
implicitly defined by property values oh
we've got great greater than less than
between okay so that's the line where we
need it
his nearest to
yep
actually let's let's break those apart
okay okay all right let's see if nearest
correctly points to nearest to probably
not yeah it does it does okay all right
anything else for nearest - mmm okay all
right what's next
construct yes we have this per construct
on curry
and this truck should be the AC but I
hope so I had some ideas about curry of
generalizations of curry that were quite
wild mm-hmm okay we say returns or Gibbs
I don't know what you prefer oh yeah and
the XX section of you I know there's
little to say it seems about this silly
um we are selling to apply we should
probably point to curry and shouldn't we
point to a composition type thing yes
what should it point to I've ever -
actually composition before coloring
apply composition perhaps mat and cover
somebody on our live stream is asking
out of curiosity how does our all from
network folder work here it's
complicated this is we do it differently
for the fix code is in get and our
documentation because it's notebooks
that contain things that get doesn't
find very friendly like big images and
so on
that's still in CVS and I'm oh so some
of the things some of the design
documents are in
in Dropbox but the the way it works is I
am extremely lazy and personally don't
use don't explicitly dude check outs
from CVS and so when I'm doing these
editing sessions
I have command line script that simply
overwrites CVS it just forces back my
changes into CVS so that's the basic Oh
somebody just reports that they just
found a bug in geo list plot yeah um
interesting okay well please head it in
or just tell us right now send it in um
okay what else
all right function what on earth felt
well most we have to say here for
construct it's it's yeah it's it's
little but I there I will link to
composition and prolly map
what about the
extremely obscure function operate but
have anything to do with this I have no
idea why are we looking what why is
composition relevant because well I I
guess because construct comes from
compose in a sense and compose was a
mixture of construct and composition hey
by the way where should I put it in this
list map scan I would say probably it
comes there yes or even before example
level okay so what are you suggesting
goes here I would add composition
what is composed lists that's
all--that's that is a function we never
use yes in fact it's it's a bit strange
that we deprecated compose but not
compose list I think we simply forgot
about compose list that's really weird
hmm well it's more useful and cut I mean
compose is really useless because with
the okay so let's just look at okay
composition why is composition relevant
to construct how do you combine
composition and construct there's an
example in construct which is trying to
to further down in scope like in
properties same thing exactly yes there
so that's what the old compose used to
do so now the action has been separated
into composition and construct which is
a lot cleaner it in case somebody wants
to do that
alright okay I get it okay well so then
composition should refer to construct
yellow at the end exactly and construct
should refer to composition
okay let's do few tries I don't think we
have to make this function experimental
I don't think that's a lot of ways it
can go wrong let's hope umm now this is
going to be used for actually the
application examples are nice here
because it shows how to do things that
were I mean we would have to use hashes
and things like that to do this before
oh look here's the thing that look
construct should function it should
refer to function yes yeah that's a good
point
actually it should arguably refer to
function pretty much first apply I think
it should refer there to function I also
think identity some what does all they
should refer to this okay and meanwhile
function lets you function
I think function should refer to this
too and function
also probably refer to curry yes
absolutely
um and by the way slot should refer to
curry as well what seemed to me yes
in curry precisely we tried to avoid
using I know but that's the point even
if you're thinking about slots then
imagine curry I mean we don't deal with
by the way we could imagine an interval
construct in curry we could imagine
saying interval 3 comma 7 which would
give you which would sort of scoop up
argument 3 through 7 yeah I have a note
at the end of the dates discussing
something in it okay alright okay
there's constructor so let's let's go to
curry now and then we've got a net to
both construct and curry the thing that
I was thinking about with curry I mean
the point about curry is that it's it's
part of the sort of family of I mean
it's it's a whole Combinator by the way
do we mention yeah we do mention
Combinator that good um the command I
have in their in their agenda is ready
to Combinator's but have a quick look at
it okay but but by the way this should
come lost yeah so I had problems with
that with the phrasing of all of this
that's why I left there alternative form
there in case you prefer it okay hold on
represent an operator form of the
function f
why do you even need to say of any
arguments well to make more explicit why
we have that in there oh I see I get it
I get it
of the function f of n arguments I think
that's reasonable I mean look I mean you
should say this but in the notes to
explain what's going on okay
yeah that's a good idea so these four
definitions are ordered in in
progressive more complicated text I know
the problem with that first one is that
people will say what on earth are you
doing why is it the wrong way around
it says by the way let's just look at
since some since somebody on our live
stream with a seemingly Japanese
username which I obviously cannot I
could put it in and transliterate it but
failing that I can't say who it is says
that this is a bug teresting just punish
cities and they're unlabeled how can
they be unlabeled why are they unlabeled
because one of them is a is it because
one of them is a as a extended region
and one of them as a point and you know
I think this is dis arginine but we have
to fix that just involves the fact that
it's two cities I I'm not sure we would
have to explore hotel
I'm just just for the hell of it I'm
just going to try this and that that
would should work right oh come on will
happen there can you do entity list
first to separate the two yes I mean
this is the this is the external change
in class entity to entity class networks
ok well that's two bugs there so that's
an entity whatever that thing is that
needs to work I think that's a new bug
because I'm sure I've done that before
we've got three bugs ok ok let's look at
the three flapping bugs
we've got Lagos with its L missing which
I consider to be fairly minor and
possibly unfixable in the current state
of things we've got the entity list
thing and we've got the to city problem
yep I mean I wonder what happens if I
say I do this yeah I think the problem
is with one extended thing and one non
extended that were my guess ok that case
irrelevant ok thank you though for the
for the bug report yank it um okay so
curry all right well let's do future I
scurry are we going to consider curry
experimental it yes please
[Music]
there could be extensions needed there
could indeed I mean the thing that I was
thinking about was named currying I'm
sure it's quite the same concept I mean
like for example with net with a neural
net stuff we have a lot of named ports
that connect to other named ports that's
a bit like like introducing variables
well okay so here's what I realized this
morning actually and I know on that
meeting the what is the difference
between named ports which are like wires
named wires and variables the answer is
wires have this property that the values
flow down the wire and are gone right
wire is connected the two ends of the
wire are connected to whatever they're
connected to the value goes through the
wire you never see the value I swear
whereas a variable has a separately
managed lifecycle so in other words the
variable might be localized it might you
know have its value localized and so on
but the variable has a life beyond the
wire so to speak I see interesting right
that's the difference whereas and what
this is if we were to wire things up
through currying and so on that would be
a non variable it has no life like you
can make a closure with you know with a
function having a variable whose value
comes from outside the function but if
you are doing it with pure wiring um
the it's some a you you can't do that by
the way the first person our live stream
and I gotta stop looking at this was
it's asking for a public bug tracker you
don't want that unless you want to spend
your life going through its some the it
is not an easy thing to figure out
what's going on it's some there is a bug
tracker and it's let's see what happens
if i press develop or open bugs what
happens
I was that add is that something
assigned to me oh wow
it's him so it's only one of it that's
amazing okay well whatever um the like
somebody should clean that out that
whatever that is it's not gonna get
looked at um okay so so even then
they're wiring some sort of scoping
which is very fast it don't exists yes
yes it is but it is essentially some
functional version of scoping that still
has names but those names those names
are more volatile than you know it's not
like a declared name I don't know I
don't I don't understand what it is
exactly but it's something you know I
think we've already invented because
what we're doing in neural net business
is we're transitioning for a wire
situation to a variable situation just
like we will also do that for the
quantum computing case right um and we
need to understand but I think what
we're seeing here is a case where we can
imagine having a sort of a ports and
wires version of any collection of
functional programming things and I
don't quite understand that yet right so
it's it's function for example we have
slot one which in a sense is a name and
here we are trying to handle things
without that intermediate that's right
without names which is what you know
that's what Shawn Fink will try to do
with combinators originally exactly and
in fact please can you go to these note
they have in there in the agenda yep
because they're I try to construct the s
and K combinators with with curry and K
is trivial but s it almost gets there in
this second oh my gosh but you see I
have no idea how to combine the Y and C
internally and I think that's that's
them that's important thing for the S
Combinator and the thing we are missing
with carrying this idea of of mapping
things very
deep into an expression which we can do
with function because no matter where we
have a slot one very deep in some other
expression the argument will get there
yes but with curry we cannot do that we
cannot map say the variable C to the Y
well okay so let's just take a look at
what this is doing so
you're Korean
what the heck does that even do so so
let's look at K first which is simpler
so K is saying take two arguments and
yes map the first way entity so we get
back X right right right right right
right
take two arguments return just the first
to use just the first of those arguments
the function is identity we get back X
okay I get it except now here somewhat
bizarrely we've got essentially a
duplication of argument we've got three
arguments and we're duplicating the
third argument the Z which is exact
that's what we do exactly in the simpler
version of this what we saying is given
this we will be we have a three argument
function right and what we will be
saying by by rights is hash one of hash
three of us for now
no like that right that's what we will
be saying yes but now now we are feeling
the four arguments birth function
because we have converted three into
four so it would be okay but we don't in
fact there and this way of doing it we
don't need to do that exactly with
function it will be just exactly what
you wrote with in fact it's just this
exactly and by the way we should put
that in the documentation that case I
mean even without scurries will work
already
because function takes three arguments
there no it won't work it won't work
look at what it's doing it's I said yes
yes yes yes this is in fact a perfect
example of currying yeah yeah exactly
and right so the issue is should we be
able to do in other words currying is
one thing currying is the the unraveling
the d tearing to use the SP terminology
of those arguments right that's one
thing now the second question is how do
we wire up those arguments and that's
what you're trying to do here yeah and
it's not obvious to me that the wiring
can be done yeah I mean this is wiring
without names you know I was I was
there's this big thick book by Hank
Barendrecht about lambda calculus you
know it's some I was I was looking at it
at some point and I thought gosh you
know in the history of lambda calculus
somebody has got to have done better you
know with all of these you know notions
of beta reduction and God knows what
else this whole business of functions
within functions and the renaming of
variables you you know there has to be
some functional way to do that but in
this book it's just like no there's this
weird de Bruyne labeling and so on that
basically isn't a solution that no one
in that whole literature I think so in a
hundred years of lambda calculus I don't
think there's a known solution to how to
unravel these things without effectively
having names like so so that was because
that's the problem we're dealing with
here is how to deal with essentially you
know I mean I suspect
okay so here's another way to think
about it another way to think about it
is imagine it's just a graph right so
because that's what this is this is a
graph feeding or a tree actually not a
graph a tree because it's it's returning
up to the root one function named by one
one value right so another way to think
about this would be forget all these
things and just feed in as that first
argument some kind of tree actually
um maybe Xavier has a savior here no yes
yes yes um the maybe you have a thought
based on your trees work about a tree
that represents a function because
you've got trees whose nodes have
functions on them right yes what is the
relationship between is there a function
tree effectively that eats that
basically eats arguments from its leaves
you see what I'm saying so in other
words what we're saying here is one way
to represent a function any one of these
functions like the S Combinator function
is to just say we've got a we've got a
tree and that the nodes of the tree are
no one functions of some kind
FG whatever else right but the leaves of
the tree labelled in some way as yet
unknown leaves of the tree are the you
know the the input are the inputs
basically did that make any sense so you
you want the leaves to be functions
themselves no no I want the leaves to be
the slots
the leaves are where the slots go in or
like placeholders yes they're like
placeholders because that's what if we
wanted to represent this thing here in a
way where we didn't have to explicitly
name one two three the way I could
imagine doing that is with essentially
you know let's imagine that this was the
thing if we said and again this is not a
very good way to do it but but let's
let's imagine we just had the tree form
of this okay and that's not the right
way to do it but there is those things
wouldn't be what would those be I don't
even know what those would be
yeah those will be constructs I think
those be yes I will let B slot three but
only one leaf
this correct so we to to to leaves but
let's slot three like just place order
instead of something like that yes yes
so this thing would be yeah that would
be I don't know where slot one goes in
here then but what I'm suggesting is
that there's a way of doing this so that
the thing you have is not a thing with
name variables it is merely a tree AC
which implicitly has names inside it
because of the way we represent well
actually doesn't necessarily have names
inside it it it has to have something
representing its unfilled leaf slots
right so so we we have investigated this
and we had these three elements bracket
bracket so nothing in it
this could be use as a placeholder okay
well so fine so that so then we've got
exactly this so we've got something with
an empty tree element that represents a
placeholder so that is our answer
I think that is what our our nameless
you know in other words what we could
imagine putting in two is it as a tree
function basically that is so in other
words what it would be is something like
it will be tree function of a tree here
and that thing would expect arguments
which correspond to the leaves of the
tree but how do we know which argument
goes to which leaving well I know
therein lies the problem because we have
to do some kind we have to have an
ordering of the tree leaves right and
and that requires depth-first
breadth-first whatever else right but
that's a traversal order we've we've
discussed for trees for other reasons if
I'm not mistaken yes but because three
sir kind of two-dimensional it's not
obvious how you do the ordering of those
things I mean we should do a
lexicographic order of part numbers
where you do it by a bunch of other
things right but my point is that I
think this is the variable list
representation of you know this thing
here
which you've managed to sort of hack
together with it with a pure korean
construct I think the correct variable
this version of that is a tree and I
agree that there's an issue about the
ordering of you know I mean again which
which which smacks a variable ISM so to
speak a variable numbering or something
like this but I do believe that the tree
is the is is kind of a generalization
that I think this is right and I think
maybe that the generalization of that
when you have shared intermediate
variables is a dag of some kind anyway
that's for the future let's put on our
list you know to look at tree function
um okay
oh boy I've got a completely different
meeting that this is colliding with all
right let's sum um I need to get to it
soon and then I have got to yeah I'm
traveling this this afternoon and this
evening so okay fine no problem all
right
so let's go look at this curry thing um
all right so the question is whether to
put this form first or not I would like
to not put it first because I think it's
like so much of the why are you doing
that it's the wrong way round type thing
yeah for some time we had a separate
function but now it has been removed
again I don't think we need a separate
function I just think we don't want to
put that as the first use case of this
okay I wonder whether we wanted it the
second use case or whether we want it
far down let's put it as the second use
case I think that's the best thing to do
hard to know I mean any of these things
could be confusing okay so do you want
to you are going to okay so this these
forms here I think we understand what
these are k argument operator form so
that blah blah blah blah now are you
proposing something with with a span I'm
sorry would be a span not an interval we
could I'm I have to think how that would
work I was thinking more in relation to
what you have on your left which is how
to do two of these functions at the same
time but that gets a bit too complicated
I think it's too complicated but what I
think is useful is the analog of hash
hash the analog of slot sequence for
curry I see I see
mm-hm yeah perhaps this pan can be done
yes all right okay so I think this is
reasonable and now the only thing we
have to do is to knit curry and
construct onto the onto the main pages
where earth does this go here with
applying functions I guess so
well the very first card operator form
is probably curry itself okay so here
okay so I guess this is what constructor
goes I would put it with Matt with a
applying functions not with functional
composition but this is applying
functions to lists E or the lists I see
I see
um well let's let's make the change here
first as we know we want that one okay
well hold on so here we clearly want
construct clearly wants to be here
yes in place of composers that's an
interesting claim right I mean it is
Glee further down but now that's alright
construct construct an expression from
heads from head and arguments yard from
its head and arguments okay
now do we want to put curry but it says
operator forms here so where are the
operator phones well there's a separate
thing with operator forms curried
operator forms about anything I mean the
title it says function composition and
operator forms okay fine all right then
so what are they great inform scheme
here where are they here functions with
operator forms oh I see so yes
let's do this let's have a delimiter
there and let's put curry here
oh my gosh now this is the the always
problem of how to describe this
maybe general function into a libertà
form okay fine okay now where does
construct go on this page if at all
I think construct deserves to go
somewhere here well let's just put
expression construction here why not
all right and then what I'm going to do
is put construct here what did I say
Freyja right construct an expression
from its head in arguments okay okay all
right I think we can declare victory
here except that there's clearly more
somebody was asking on the lifestream
here by the way about our tree thing is
it just about injecting data into the
computation graph yes basically I mean
we're this is defining well it's a
little complicated because one of these
trees is a symbolic representation an
unavailing it's a this requires a bit
more thought I mean this is kind of like
the quintessential issue of yeah the
difference between you know there are
these two forms of recursion that we
always end up having male never mind
this is a long discussion I mean when
you have some thing where there's one
form of recursion which is repeated
evaluation of something and the other
form of recursion is going through an
expression tree
yeah those have a complicated
relationship all right anyway it's some
I think we this is great so good I think
that's it let me just push back
since some since somebody was asking
about how this actually works I will
show the horrifying thing that actually
happens here this is pushing back the
things we just worked on I'm very very
primitive really um okay right let's
let's um okay wrapping this up actually
I'm about to go to another meeting which
is also on a live stream Oh somebody is
making a suggestion here all right one
last thing we're gonna look at a nested
tree okay let me copy this out we have
two comments here um a nested tree could
be used yes yes well we have trees we
have a function that turns that is
called rule rule tree right that turns
that into a tree is that correct
it won't be the same syntax yes it's
based on rule but it is not supported by
by combining thoughts you directly
linked parent to its children with rule
so there is no comma separated
expression linked okay but by the way
okay this other comment a special way to
specify mixed arity of a function I
don't think that's right I think that
this is I'm not sure quite what that is
referring to because the so carry will
not take will not express a function of
different parties it has to have a
definite clarity so with carry would you
cannot say a function of two or three
arguments because they need to yes I
understand right I mean I don't think
that makes any sense for curry I don't
see how curry could ever deal with that
story doesn't know it is it is it is a
primitive you know dating as it does
from the 1920s it is a primitive form of
functional application
boy that must have been confusing I mean
you know to people who think about math
and think about functions as mappings
from spaces to spaces and so on the
whole business with you know the Hilbert
style you know
and then shown Finkle style Combinator
thing must be I mean III can see why the
you know obviously the pointer a style
of mathematicians with the spaces
displaces business very different from
these structural things what anyway okay
but let's just look at this for a second
so for the first of all Wall Street we
will need something like 0 goes to 1
goes to 3 goes to least and so on but
the idea is interesting maybe we will
have an expression because from
expression 3 and to expression we can go
back and forth from a tree to an
expression yes so we could have an
option like Sloat or something like that
because we are using structure is the
idea of structure on how to interpret a
tree tronex question so we can we could
have something like that to interpret a
tree as a function without yeah I think
that's interesting but but but so you're
right I mean it's really a way it's a it
kind of bent begins to bring together
sort of in the visual programming
metaphor and so on where we have graphs
representing I mean you know okay so one
thing that we obviously have we can
easily represent a chain of functions
right that's a you know it's just a
composition right we have a very
straightforward way to do that so the
question is what's the generalization
you know we say F G H of X right and we
have that um the question is if you
don't want the data to flow well there's
there's two problems first of all if you
you know when you have multiple legs for
each function here I mean look this is
this is another rediscovery of the exact
same thing that one talks about
right this is like tensor calculus to
where you have where things have
multiple legs and they have to be
knitted together correctly and the
tensor stuff is very similar to the
neural net stuff um although not quite
the same because well neural Nets are
using tensors they're not using it in
the same way well am I making any sense
I mean okay how does this relate okay
the physics moment here how does this
relate so when we look at like tensor
expressions as represented by like the
hole Penrose diagram attic thing those
are mostly contractions is that true yes
indeed and what is the relationship
between a tensor contraction and any of
this kind of connecting an argument here
you know and this sort of computation
graph thing
so the contractions basically would be
like having the same variable in
simultaneously in several places so you
need to say somehow these variable here
and this variable here are the same
variable right that's exactly what we've
got with these wires exactly exactly so
that's that's a contraction it has that
in tensor case you always impose that
there are two contracted but you can
image you could imagine there are many
of them contracted simultaneously and
why is it the case that in tensor
calculus that you only ever have I mean
usually with tensor calculus you're
doing the Einstein summation convention
on the contractions that's a yes right
do that but that's a but that's usually
in the contraction that's what you mean
you're doing isn't it that you're
tracing over that that that that
contracted index I mean yeah whereas in
the more general case one could just say
those indices have to be the same but
are not summed over am I getting
confused here
well yes it do the difference is having
a table versus having a sum so the
notation for the table and some are the
same you know have in this is repeated
and you can have and then if you put
around the whole things or table in the
tensor case is some in in this other
case is more like table right
there's a nice unification that we can
do here but we it needs more work this
is gonna be fun but not for today go
ahead no I have a notebook I can show
you at some other point dedicated to
this unification you know in which you
can have a general head which is neither
some nor table and it's it's coordinate
I will show you something
what do you now I'm now I'm curious what
earth you mean by that so so imagine we
have table and some food stakes indices
and then the expression in the first
argument can have repeated indices or
not I'm coming imagine that you have a
function that can take other heads not
only table and some oh yeah right we
thought about that before in fact that
was even in that was that was a design
in version one and in fact it even had a
name I see what was it called it was it
was a generalization of sum and products
and all those kinds of things exactly so
it is it is the it is a bit like outer
but it isn't outer it's something yes I
remember that was a it had a name um it
had a name it's it's probably in the
yeah well maybe finally now after 30
years we actually need that function
alright time to go to the next meeting
okay okay see you later